[Musique]
au milieu du massif des carapatte une
citadelle vertigineuse entouré de
profondes forêts abritent depuis des
siècles une terrible dynastie de olin de
wolfsburg karim r et u la connaissais
même pas d'homme
prépare toi on y va repartir dans un
royaume plein de loups moi je te le dis
tout de suite à ancenis
[Musique]
l'établissement n'accepte pas les
clients comment dire à poil bizarre
quand même de penser que toi tu vient
semer bière javaux la peluche je vous
demande de reposer doucement montmagny
kahlo port-au-prince carette a prévenu
laval fans berg les amis vous venez pour
le festival de cannes je suppose et wall
e festival de cannes car ma cheville
je vous présente lauda victor von baer
[Musique]
lapin de balle maintenant comme al peco
mai dernier chérie fais tes valises on
se casse chez nous un jour
pendant que tu joues à devenir un vrai
loup moi je dors à lure ce ring mais
vous n'êtes qu'une captain commando
libération vote
les nouveaux publics vous pouvez nous
suivre dans la forêt vous est en grand
danger
oh non
regardes tu vas voir c'est de montrer un
truc de l'eau jusqu'aux genoux comprends
pas normalement la lune apparaît quand
on fait ça je craque
d'habitude ça marche